well welcome to another Python tutorial
this tutorial is gonna be covering
spreadsheet manipulation within Python I
believe at least in Excel you can do
pretty big commands and I think there's
a few other like spreadsheet
applications that you can purchase and I
don't know anything about like Macs and
all that but I know I don't have Excel
and the Google Doc spreadsheet doesn't
really give you the opportunity to apply
the bulk amount like let's say you want
to apply a formula to a hundred thousand
rows there's no way to do that
immediately at least not that I know of
if you do know away great also the other
downside is you can't really apply a
really tricky formulas and if you can
it's like you add 15 layers at least to
that trickiness right to do it within a
spreadsheet it's just like really
confusing with the whole columns and
rows and the numbers and the symbols and
it's just a huge mess so if you can
learn to do the manipulation within
Python just makes things a lot easier so
that's what we're gonna be doing in this
video as long as you already have Python
great if you don't already have Python
then you need to pop over to Python org
and download Python one sec I'll bring
it over so this is Python org all you do
is go to download and download Python
2.7 and get either 64-bit or 32-bit
depending on your system so once you
have that the next thing that we're
going to need is actually numpy I
imagine a lot of my viewers already have
numpy but if you don't then you're gonna
go over to Google here and oh cool it's
falling apart again this is why we can't
have nice things
guys anyway we're gonna search numpy
Python 2.7 here search that oh goodness
so probably the best thing to do we get
to the pi pi package index and download
and install for python 2 7 now if you're
operating on a 64-bit version of python
then this will not
no it's not gonna work out for you very
well so the next thing you're gonna want
to do if you're on 64-bit Python which
you should be so if you ever want to
edit files larger than two gigabytes you
can the other option is to go to this
website over here and I'll try to
remember to put this link in the
description wait here's a bunch of
binaries for Python and you can download
64-bit binaries so we can go numpy here
and all of these packages require an
umpire's so that's why we're finding a
bunch of it but eventually we get to
numpy and this will be where you want to
download if you have a 64-bit you'll
download this one right here and that'll
make it real easy to get numpy so once
you've done that you'll want to make
sure that you've done it so go over to
your Start bar bring up the Python
command line looks something like this
and if you don't know what bit version
of Python you have you can kind of
scroll over and see right here it'll
tell you and I have 64-bit and make sure
you can do the following import oh my
goodness can't tell you important I'm PI
like that and as long as you don't have
any errors you're free to continue if
you do have errors and you can't figure
it out leave a comment below and I'll do
my best to help you out with that let's
go ahead and get right to it so I've got
a blank Python window here if you don't
how to get there go to your Start bar
type in IDE and what will pop up is
something pretty similar to what we were
just looking on actually it looks like
this then you can go to file new window
opens up this little untitled window
then you can save it make sure when you
hit save you save it as whatever the
file type is plus py so let me bring it
over and I'll hit save as and you'll see
here there's a bunch of files here you
know first of all pick whatever
directory you're gonna be working in but
when you save the file name you'll just
do file name and don't forget to do dot
py otherwise I'll save it as like a
regular file and it's really annoying so
once you've done that you should have
you know window like this I'm calling
mine CSB minute so the first thing that
we're going to need to do is go ahead
and import numpy as NP just so we can
shorthand the numpy when we need it next
we're going to define our main and
within here I always like to put
everything and try and accept loops that
makes it easier when the program fail
so I'm gonna put try and then accept
exception with a capital e and then
we're gonna call that an E and then
we'll just print string e now in our try
loop this is where we're gonna actually
start using numpy so the file that I've
got here is going to be to cheat dot CSV
so it's just kind of a sample file here
and in fact I'm gonna do you all this
solid and give you guys this exact sheet
one sec so if you want to follow on
exactly what the tutorial go-to syntax
comm slash and Tut sheet dot CSV hit
enter and that will download the to the
same sheet that I'm working with so you
can work alongside with exactly the same
stuff that we're using you don't have to
but you don't have to but it will it
could make it easier if you're confused
so with that this is the file as you can
see we've got date here we've got this
little arbitrary name here we're saying
gbp/usd and we've got an arbitrary
number here and as we can see it really
is separated by a comma
spreadsheets don't have to be literally
CSV which stands for comma separated
variable but they can and this one is
going to be so what we're going to do
now is with numpy numpy has a built-in
functionality called load text it's also
got something like gen text or something
like that that you can use it just it
really doesn't matter so the next thing
that we're going to do is define the
variables here and as you can see we've
got like date this is a Forex rate or a
ratio so it will just say date here rate
and then we'll call this arbitrary
number or something so what we do is you
define the variables so date rate and
then parb for arbitrary number and this
these three variables will equal NP for
that numpy that we short-handed dot load
text so load txt and the file path if
the files in the same directory as this
script then you can just do what I'm
doing here and just type it in so touch
sheet dot CSV and the next thing we can
specify is the delimiter so
come down yes here and say delimiter
equals and our delimiter is a comma in
this case it can be anything you want
this you just specify it here and unpack
needs to be true so we can do this right
here so we can specify like multiple
variables and then finally D tight is
gonna need to be string and that is
because date is a string variable and so
is the label even so we need that to be
that way now the next thing that we're
gonna do here in the last part of this
video anyways is just show you guys how
this works if you're not comfortable
with this like multiple variable kind of
thing but if like say we want the right
here this is each column right this is
the date column so everything like in
date it'll print out all of the dates in
that comma or column so if we just call
date or Lissa's pre date like this
we'll save that and let's run that and
we haven't called main yet so we'll just
type out main to call it and this gives
us an array of all of our dates
subsequently the next thing you can do
is you can do like date you get like the
five it's not the fifth element it's
actually the sixth element everything
starts at zero just in case you didn't
know date and then rate five and armed
five will run this again and if you
don't know how to run anything I guess I
didn't say anything but there is a run
button here or you can hit f5 and again
will call main and now we can see the
sixth row the day gbpusd and the numbers
and obviously they're not comma
separated you could kind of like
superimpose some in there but you don't
need to so those are just the basics of
like loading it getting numpy if you
don't have it in python if you don't
have it and how this works in the next
video i'm gonna be showing you guys how
to actually be in manipulation now if
all you really wanted to do is say get
rid of a column you could just basically
leave it out and then make a for loop
which i'll show you guys in a little bit
but if you could do this where it just
prints the date and the arbitrary number
right and so you've already taking it
out so you can get remove columns pretty
easily now you can remove columns really
easily
like Google Docs and most spreadsheets
as well so I imagine the application of
formulas to rows and making like a new
column is what most people are
interested in so we will be getting to
that but in the next video so as always
thanks for watching thanks for the
support of the subscriptions and until
next time